car dans sans filtre tout de suite
maintenant on bat son coeur dans 100
foot
[Musique]
le quart d'heure sans fil comprenez vous
la colère des téléspectateurs et on va
vous l'expliquer ceux qui pensent que
oui se mettent à droite ceux qui pensent
que non se mettent à gauche pour le
moment on va revenir bien sûr sur
l'émission d'hier
l'émission d'hier l'amour est dans le
pré car quand même pas mal marché même
si les gens sont un peu moins bonne que
les os mais alors sur la surface cette
semaine il gagne 350 5000
téléspectateurs son deuxième de la
soirée 4 millions de téléspectateurs 18%
part d'audience est leader sur les
femmes responsables des achats
après de vaud 26% alors on a résumé pour
vous de l'émission d'hier et c'est vrai
que sur twitter sur les réseaux sociaux
ça se plaignait beaucoup de l'émission
d'hier je vais vous dire pourquoi et
après on parlera de guy qui est un
candidat qui a été harcelé vous allez
voir il ya une phrase qui est folle dans
le témoignage de guy pour le moment
regardez c'est et tire parti hier soir
il y avait l'amour est dans le pré
l'émission les matins commence comme ça
[Musique]
et où on drague comme ça tu thomas
généraux au fond bref c'est parti pour
le résumer d'hyères sequencer deuxième
moitié de séjour à la ferme et beaucoup
d'émotion au programme
[Musique]
voilà vous dire qu'il se dit de très
belles choses j'aime bien ton dégagement
dernière donc aucune des gages aux dons
des très jolis endroits du côté de raul
et lætitia le couple qui ne sert à rien
à part voir des images de la réunion on
se serait cru dans un épisode des
mystères de l'amour mais j'ai pas de
mots c'est juste magnifique
j'étais juste mais l'échec une ambiance
romantique comme chez jean-claude ah non
sinon en vrac on a assisté à la scène
d'adieu la plus nulle de l'histoire de
l'émission
mais bon retour bon je veux quelque
chose je veux tellement ça va merci non
bon allez bientôt vous allez au revoir à
bas on a encore un doute concernant
cette voix off notre agriculteur n'a
même pas eu le temps de sortir sa gaule
qu'il a déjà une voire deux touches
et si on en croit les réactions des
téléspectateurs sur les réseaux sociaux
cette saison est loin de faire
l'unanimité
alors comprenez vous la colère des
téléspectateurs alors ce qu'ils pensent
ce qu'ils comprennent la colère ce mec
là ceux qui comprennent pas de l'état
on vous a demandé aussi votre avis alors
je regarde adp depuis la première saison
c'est la première année où je me fais
littéralement chier cette saison adp
confirme je ne trouve plus aucun intérêt
dans cette émission c'est tellement
choquant cette année on nous avait
pourtant promis une super saison
la fin de l'amour est dans le pré
j'accroche pas trop à cette saison
l'amour est dans le pré c'est vrai que
voilà plein de tweetie hier alors les
internautes sont énervés contrôle manque
de bons personnages dans le casting
savent y en a deux qui ressort quand
même du lourd mais ils sont très énervés
ce que vous comprenez maxime gay ni
évidemment soporifique
sopo réfère j'adore l'amour est dans le
pré mais fédéral de constater qu'il y
ait des épisodes extrêmement inégaux
d'une semaine à l'autre
les couples et il se passe rien parfois
on s'ennuie corruption lui comme un rat
mort pendant 30 minutes sur un épisode
de 52 est vraiment un souci là dessus
la diversité et le casting est bien
présente dans les histoires racontées ça
manque de suspense de rebondissements et
de clash
il a été bon et qu'il avait
il faudrait valérie bénaïm faudrait
savoir vous n'avez pas cessé de dire que
c'était une émission qui était devenu
une émission de télé réalité que les
candidats que trop castet que c'était
des personnages que c'était plus des
personnes mais des personnages
caricaturaux bon ok on veut curie
maintenant que ça devient la vraie vie
c'est à dire assurer éventuellement des
trucs un peu chiant pourquoi pas eh ben
vous du débat non mais il se passe plus
rien on n'a pas scénarisée bas il
faudrait savoir vous êtes complètement
incohérent consistant alors les chéris
il ya quand même un couple qui se
détache qui vit une belle histoire
d'amour
regardez c'est laeticia et raul
[Musique]
bref
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est tellement ennuyeux que c'est dans
les commentaires que c'était les
réaliser oui glagow j'ai passé 17 ans
jama alors voilà je trouve honnêtement
que d'abord moi j'ai jamais aimé ce
programme vous le savez je trouve que
c'est pas du tout un prof qui met en
avant ce milieu après ce qu'on se moque
toujours alors bien sûr détriment et
surtout là maintenant les commentaires
fusent et moi on en peut pas mais c'est
toujours ça l'a surtout la ceinture
serait plateau la touche le machin je me
mets dans le pot marocaine à lhassa vous
avait choqué devant chamakh est en jeu
ça va pas alors que je suis folle
isabelle morini-bosc vous vous trouvez
que moi je la colère des téléspectateurs
n'est pas justifiée moi je trouve que il
ya une colère de téléspectateurs que
franchement ça dépend des personnes de
nos gentils et les boulders était
indéniablement nom et chérie les ajouts
dit valérie sur les notions totalement
les gens écrivent le sahraoui mais bon
les assauts radié pour cela arrive vous
dites vous dites c'est monté s'est
ennuyé tout c'est exactement comme dans
la vraie vie c'est à dire que ceux qui
sont vivants sont vivants à l'antenne ce
qu'ils sont ennuyeux sont ennuyeux
l'antenne effectivement hier soir ces
mêmes scènes de salades à manger avec un
roquefort ça prenait une stérilisation
les on sait pas vous donner envie de
regarder y avait des scènes cd avec six
devraient à côté non vous n'êtes pas
s'entraîner c'est chiant c'est ça la vie
maintenant là les mots chocs telles
missions t'as pas envie de regarder un
truchement des autres aussi je veux
citer des prénoms je voulais répondre à
isabelle non mais je vais aller son côté
parce que jean michel lemaire dit
n'importe quoi comme d'habitude tout à
l'avant du même côté je te rappelle
alors tous à l'arrivée c'est bien c'est
la vie c'est ennuyeux c'est beau il ya
des larmes et tout ça à bombannes on
excuse moi juste un ce programme c'est
juste insupportable à ce que c'est
toujours acheter chez eux ça c'est bon
vous savez pas c'est une passion
d'ailleurs c'est c'est exactement la
même chose c'est le même genre de
programme un peu à la chlorophylle pour
le premier et dans un café pour le 2ème
genre premier baiser c'est insupportable
moi je trouve que tout est trafiquée
manigancé on se moque des agriculteurs
alors je sais qu'elle a surtout annoncé
malgré ton des extraits ici des dalles
et poulter le public se marre il ya
toujours un truc un peu paris versus la
conscience très très déplacé et
d'ailleurs moi je conseille aux
agriculteurs qui cherche l'amour d'aller
sur un site qui s'appelle vachement
point fr je croyais pas chier et ben
voilà il ya des dépôts cdc pour les
amoureux kevin vatant du site de jean
marc morandini nous arrange ou encore ce
soir je sais que vous avez reçu beaucoup
si vous avez reçu beaucoup de
témoignages aussi sur votre site de deux
ans qui disait se faisait chier cette
année dans l'amour et oui bien sûr mais
faut quand même pas oublier que
l'audience a quand même 4 millions garde
fait toujours un carton moi j'adore mais
voilà c'est toujours facile de dire je
ne regarde pas c'est comme à l'époque où
va ce monde et de toutes été arrêtées
personne ne regarde même temps les
audiences part d'elle-même exactement
très focus nous avons l'expression mais
oui on est très hypocrite non il ya
quand même qualifié puis c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui
l'émission ne bénéficie pas non plus une
programmation qui est top comme la
première fois qu'elle n'est pas diffusée
l'été c'est un programme estival aussi
forcément quand on regarde cette
émission à la rentrée on n'est pas dans
le même moule dans le même état d'esprit
que sur leurs gardes au mois d'août
tranquillement parce que voilà on veut
des histoires d'amour et tout ça et
surtout dorénavant il ya beaucoup plus
d'épisodes qui dit plus d'épisodes dit
forcément audio ont séjourné qui n'avait
voilà exactement
et forcément aujourd'hui on va se dire
j'ai pas regardé je regarde pas ce soir
tant pis je regarde tous les jours il
veut me faire dix fois 4 millions que
trois fois 6 millions
alors les chéris il ya un autre truc qui
s'est passé c'est guy un candidat alors
une prétendante unitaire d'une interview
d'un candidat de l'amour est dans le pré
fait beaucoup parler depuis hier
puisqu'un candidat donc dit voilà c'est
donc s'égaillent se faire car je sais
qu'on soutient riz et c'est vrai que
c'est le symbole c'est l'amour dans le
bail est celle ci était très très proche
de lui dans l'aventuré regardez et vous
allez voir son témoignage des ouf
je suis vraiment contente de tomber sur
une
voilà sur une personne qui me correspond
pas
voilà j'ai perdu en touche mans aurélien
salmon tout le temps oui ça me dit c'est
pas loin comme ça en corse malouas salut
que tu as ton bâton on dirait moïse on
va vers la terre promise
j'ai pardonné
[Musique]
bon jeu où frau feydeau vous chauffer
l'eau chauffée alors donc il était très
proche de faux ainsi que du coup il n'a
pas hésité à mettre fin à sa relation
avec laeticia voilà on va voir tout de
suite et après vous allez voir ce qui
s'est passé avec consignes c'est vous
qui va contredire mais non nous ne
sommes pas plus loin du compte pour moi
et voilà bon débat suscite inquiète pas
on n'était pas assez présent pour moi tu
es passé présent oui mais la mort moi
j'avais besoin de ces jeunes qui sont
toujours mon ami alors il a témoigné
lundi à paris dans le cependant le speed
dating j'avais donné mon numéro de
téléphone à francine j'avais eu un coup
de coeur pour elle je lui ai dit
regretter je n'étais même pas revenu de
paris qu elle m'appelait m'envoyer des
sms me demander mots de virer montserrat
et cetera
voilà je lui répondais pas mais elle
continuait de me lâcher plus la garde
le premier soir l abus de ricard les
trois quarts des bouteilles de rosé ou
un verre de rouge pour accompagner le
fromage elle s'est servie de la dr
d'autres même chose le lendemain elle
voulait même du champagne elle était
gonflé il a même révélé à quel point
france il est entreprenante dans
l'épisode elle tente de m'embrasser
pendant que je fais la vaisselle
elle venait frapper à ma porte la nuit
je n'ai pas du tout apprécié surtout
qu'elle ne voulait pas jouer le jeu de
l'émission elle me décembre elle me
demandait sans cesse de virer les
cameramans j'ai donc arrêté l'hémorragie
tout de suite et lui a demandé de partir
elle m'a harcelé mais je ne voulais
surtout pas lui répondre j'ai coupé
court
quant à montserrat à la contacter la
production pour revenir mais je n'ai pas
répondu je leur rappellerai quand la
saison sera terminée en ami qu'elle ne
se fasse pas d'illusion voilà j'ai eu un
problème il ya une erreur et il a donné
son numéro guy à la prétendante et la
production recommande toujours de ne
jamais fils ait quoi que ce soit en
matière de randonnée jusqu'au tournage
dans la ferme parce que la production
en parallèle mène des enquêtes sur les
prétendantes c'est ce qu'on fait ici
mais moi j'ai pas vos numéros
en cas de harcèlement et en cas de
harcèlement la production contacter la
prétendante lui rappelle les règles
d'usagé et que le l'agriculteur peut
porter plainte individuelle de l'armée
parle au nom de m on va apprendre à geek
est une fonction qui permet de bloquer
un numéro si vraiment on est harcelé
suffit de faire ça comme le soleil
oui c'est elle du module fixé mois et
donc pareil de balancer sur la candidate
de presse et prennent d'alcool et de
calvaire en plus il a kiffé bien savoir
ils venaient chercher l'amour et
visiblement elle voulait lui en offrir
un moment les plages immenses et pardon
mais elle est tactile
il pourrait y aurait pu lui dire écoute
pour l'instant si tu vois un petit peu
vite pour moi
[Applaudissements]
il est basique oui nous si le mec il a
absolument pas fait pour être mariées et
ça va se terminer en naufrage pour les
deux et on voit bien il le regarde à
aucun moment il ne les regardent en face
à aucune gêne et la pauvreté les caméras
il est passé pour être marié c'est un
vieux gars faut l'admettre édition
verdez franchement le harcèlement c'est
grave et c'est pas ça c'est ce geek est
détestable août l'émission il a gâché
l'émission il a été nul elles ont bien
fait de partir ne doivent pas le
regretter sa mort moi je veux récupérer
les meufs
c'est des agriculteurs comme ça qu'ils
foutent en l'air la saison que vous avez
des personnages qui sont caricaturaux
agressive les gens c'était une émission
bon enfant vous dire quel anniversaire
de karine il y avait deux marcheuses
agriculteurs dans plusieurs de cette
année aymeric le sap ineris et les 300
bébés on sait qu'ils étaient franchement
très heureux d'être là et qui soutenait
qu'il n'y avait pas d'internet
merci merci isabelle parce qu'on va
parler de karine le marchand à l'aide de
la mairie de repris depuis 8 ans elle
est bien installé dans cette émission
mais est-ce qu'elle va pas arrêter moi
je me suis posé une question hier je
vous la poser hier j'ai vu julia vignali
dans mon admirateur secret et je me suis
demandé si karine ne préparait pas son
départ de l'amour est dans le pré parce
que c'est vrai que on a senti que julia
vignali et karine le marchand c'est un
peu le même style d'animation et je me
demande si karine n'a pas envie
peut-être de passer à autre chose ça
fait huit ans qu'elle le fait regardez
où vous a fait un petit comparatif
elles sont les deux visages des
émissions de dating de m6 d'un côté
karine le marchand dans l'amour est dans
le pré
bonjour bonjour et de l'autre julia
vignali dans mon admirateur secret deux
animatrices différentes mais un style
très similaire toujours dans l'empathie
avec les candidats que ce soit dans la
manière de dire bonjour
j'arrête de râler dans les expressions
ben vas-y raconte traitement quoi bon
allez go on a mangé par un coup à boire
un coup ou dans les gestes jeu long du
mall signaux alors karine lemarchand
bientôt remplacé alors karine le
marchand est ce que vous pensez que
julia vignali peut remplacer
karine le marchand est ce que vous
pensez que karine le marchand va arrêter
l'amour est dans le pré
dites la vérité ici oui ou non vos kevin
vous dis toi ah non pas du tout non pour
moi d'urines le marchand elle incarne le
programme le programme c'est llc le
programme c'est non pour moi non vrai
les géniales karine parle d'un gars mais
l'histoire inkari ça peut faire beaucoup
d'autres choses aussi insurgée dans
l'est ça c'est autre chose
julien vinyle aujourd'hui personne ne la
connaît celui-ci bon s'arrêter
le programme et le poids mais plus fort
que l'animatrice son car il a bien animé
en premier les roannais nick green hier
puisque je suis bien d'accord
oula frères tavernost le patron de m6 a
toujours dit que pour lui le plus avancé
pas l'animateur mais le format concert
de la star c'est le format est pas
l'animateur donc je pense mauvaise
saison pour karine le marchand
mais parce que moi je savais que j'adore
mais elle a porté cette saison à l'as
dit ce sera la meilleure le casting est
formidable on voit les gens sont se
déchaîne sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est une calamité ça se passait en
audience mais le contrat est nul et
c'est pas hasard en télé juste après
elle vous avez julia vignali qui arrive
dans une émission de dating c'est pour
lui faire je crois peur il n'y a pas de
hasard en télé je suis désolé on lui met
quelqu'un comme elle juste après à
l'antenne c'est une manière de lui dire
nations face à murray c'est bon ça j'ai
l'impression qu'on va en recommandé
non merci laisser parler maxime 15 pour
la prochaine saison est en cours de
production avec dans les rangs karine le
marchand
ramage et des visas livre là un humour
très gaulois karina que seule l unique
en son genre à tourner les portraits
d'accord très bien alors vous vous dites
non plus moi j'ai donc même si le
programme cette année on trouve qu'il a
ralenti c'est vrai ils mangent des
salades crudités celle en moi si tu
enlèves si tu enlèves tahri or et argent
il ya plus de programmes parce que vous
êtes bien sentir on adorable et les
réseaux sociaux les réseaux sociaux
arreteig des réseaux sociaux il ya 4
millions de personnes qui ont regardé
ses papiers mais l'émission pas relève
karine marchand il l'a dit c'est quoi
c'est quoi le moktad il a pu être
inquiétés d'un gala car nos programmes
destinés à tout ce qu'il dit l'effort
était que les réseaux sociaux c'est la
télé c'est pas que les réseaux sociaux
qui commande c'est des gens qui nous
montrent g jean-michel non à la capa le
programme tu mets n'importe qui d'autre
on a dit que si on changeait génériques
j'adore quand on a dix questions pour un
champion on a dit les amours allait
s'arrêter ça continue ça marche mais
theurillat ce pont sal alors qu'elle est
pas responsable de la chute probable
même si cela fonctionnera faut pas qu'on
fait charlie effectivement car une tient
parfaitement
bah oui c'est la meilleure a pas de
raison à mon avis pour sofia - problème
si je suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec
jean michel pense que si on la change
est il est possible que ça met un peu de
temps avant de le reprendre
on met alors valérie et sauve sa propre
lassitude ça fait huit ans qu'un incarne
le programme c'est nature qu'est ce qui
peut faire tellement d'autres choses
peut-être qu'elle a elle aussi demandé à
une transition en douceur je ne sais
l'axé dax et aix et tex et julien lepers
est une mécanique de jeu posé sur un
plateau là elle va vers les gens pour
rien car élevé ces bretons quand on
regarde on est dans le pré ça toujours
très très bien pas toujours questionné
alors karine est la meilleure moi je
pense n'être d'anglais mais ça que ça
marche alors on va voir ce que vous en
pensez
et alors bonne idée 46% mauvaise et 54%
mais je sais c'est pas mal quand même
pour julia vignali qui commence mal un
ipad